this is a production of Cornell
University
and what my lab is interested in is the
interaction between bacterial pathogens
and plants and today I'm going to talk
about two different projects in a lab
one is focused on the role of plant
kinase a''s in regulating plant immune
responses and the second is work on
bacterial canker of tomato disease
that's caused by xylem limiting
bacterium and some of our work
understanding what regulates bacterial
virulence in that system so plants have
a variety of different associations with
microorganisms in nature and also in
agriculture and this significantly
shapes plant health and productivity in
these landscapes and so I'm sure we're
all aware that there are positive
associations between different
microorganisms and plants like that of
nitrogen fixing bacteria or mycorrhizae
fungi that enable nutrient acquisition
but what we're interested in in my group
are these negative associations or
pathogens that can infect plants and
decreased crop yields and so we work on
some leaf leaf pathogens like
Pseudomonas syringae and we are also
working on vascular pathogens that can
infect tomato as well as citrus and one
of the reasons why I became interested
as a younger scientist in plant
pathology and decided to pursue that was
because plant pathogens can really
significantly impact agricultural
production and in addition there's
always a lot of very interesting plant
diseases that are continuously emerging
as well as really important
long-standing diseases so I'm just
illustrating a few here so banana is
particularly problematic for plant
disease and it's currently being
affected by a number of different fungal
pathogens including microcell a fijian
psious and this is because all banana
that we eat is clonally propagated and
derived from a single clone called
Cavendish
so that makes breeding for resistance
very difficult because there's no
genetic diversity they are to draw from
and so because of that there's lots of
fungicide sprays that are sprayed arioli
over
Anna plantations multiple times even
within a week in a growing season
another really important disease is
citrus greening or huanglongbing
this is a long-standing disease but it's
emerged recently within the United
States it's severely impacted citrus
production in Florida there's been about
five billion dollars worth of loss in
the last five or six years and it's
thought that almost all trees in Florida
are now infected it's transmitted by a
psyllid it's very hard to control a
flying insect and we now know that the
disease is present in Texas the psyllids
established in California and there are
diseased trees within the Los Angeles
area and now we know that that's
spreading within the LA County area of
California and so this is an important
emerging disease within the u.s. there
are also long-standing diseases that
still retain importance like late blight
of potato and tomato caused by the oh my
seat Phytophthora infestans and here you
can see the importance of genetic
resistance where you have one row of
potato that possesses an immune receptor
that can recognize the pathogen and
another row that lacks the corresponding
immune receptor is and is decimated by
the disease so genetic resistance can be
quite robust the issue is is that some
immune receptors can be rapidly overcome
by the pathogen population and then
there's also been quite a bit of basic
research on plant microbe interactions
that have really significantly enhanced
our understanding of genome engineering
and editing in plants also hormone
perception and receptor perception as
well so we work on the plant innate
immune systems the plants don't actually
have adaptive immunity like you and I do
they don't have specialized immune cells
that can circulate but what they do have
is a large number of germline encoded
receptors that can specifically
recognize all classes of paths
so there are receptors that are present
on the cell surface called pattern
recognition receptors that can
specifically recognize conserved
microbial features called PAMP sore
ramps examples of this would be
bacterial flagella nor fungal chitin and
these surface localized receptors
recognize these microbial signatures as
non-self commonly function in
conjunction with a co-receptor and then
elicit pattern triggered immune
responses and resistance so pathogens
need to be able to be adapted to inhibit
plant immune responses if they want to
be able to cause disease and one way
that pathogens can do this is by
delivery of pathogen proteins called
effectors into plant cells and these
effectors or characterized effectors can
disrupt plant immune signaling they can
target the receptors themselves or
downstream immune signaling components
and these effectors can still be
recognized in certain plant genotypes by
the presence of plant resistance genes
I'll call them NL arse but basically
resistance gene and an NL R can be
interchangeable
they're called NL R's because they have
a nucleotide binding site and c-terminal
leucine-rich repeat and these NL ARS can
recognize the presence of pathogen
effectors trigger robust defense
responses and effector triggered
immunity and historically it was thought
that these are two distinct branches of
plant immune signaling but now we know
that it's kind of more of a complicated
web and there's significant overlap and
immune signaling networks between pti
and ETI and then plants also have large
Arsenal's of immune receptors so if you
look in plant genomes and you're just
looking at these our proteins or NL ours
that can recognize intracellular
effectors they range on the low end of
about 54 in papaya to the high end of
around a thousand and domesticated apple
and the repertoire differs significantly
even
among different genotypes of a
particular plant
there's also large numbers of receptor
like kinase Azure receptor like proteins
these do control a range of processes
but at least a subset are going to be
involved in pathogen perception and in
the model plant to have a topsis there's
600 of these and the number is just
increasing for NLRs as well with the
advent of aren't ren seek to identify
more NLR receptors in plants so in my
lab we work on three different pathogens
and i'll talk about two of them today
one disease that we work on is called
bacterial spec it's caused by
Pseudomonas syringae path of our tomato
and it can infect both tomato and a
rabbit OPS's and cause these necrotic
specks during later stages of disease
and that's where the disease got its
name we're primarily I'll focus today on
our work with Pseudomonas syringae and a
rabid OPS's the other pathogen that we
work on is klava bacter michigan ANSYS
and this causes bacterial canker of
tomato you can see some of the symptoms
here
it's called canker because during later
stages of disease the bacteria will
induce the stem to split open and this
is caused to called a canker where then
bacteria can use out and serve as a
secondary source of an ocular and if
there's a lot of bacteria around during
flowering you can get fruit symptoms as
well and so here we're interested in
we've performed some genome sequencing
of a variety of different Club of actor
Michigan ants it's isolates and use that
for diagnose diagnostic testing as well
as to gain insight into conserved
virulence mechanisms present in collabo
doctor and then I won't talk about this
project but I'd be happy to talk with
anyone afterwards we're also working on
citrus greening or flan lung Bing here
we're primarily interested in
investigating the role of secreted
bacterial proteins called the factors
and what their plant targets are during
infection so first I'll talk about
Pseudomonas syringae and our work with
the rabbit OPS's and if you look at
Pseudomonas syringae it can be divided
into different paths of ours and each
path of our can cause a distinct disease
and Pseudomonas in general are pretty
good epified so if you go out and surf
it sample the surface of a plant leaf
you'll see that Pseudomonas are a core
component of the phyla sphere microbiome
but pathogenic Pseudomonas you need to
gain entry into the plant interior in
order to cause disease and they can do
this by swimming through open stomata or
wounds were then they multiply in the
ape last or the space between mesophyll
cells and if it's a susceptible genotype
that lacks corresponding immune
receptors you can get quite high
bacterial titers and invisible disease
symptoms so first I want to talk about
our our work focusing on how these
intracellular NLR immune receptors are
activated
so these NL are receptors have a
conserved domain architecture they would
have either a coil coil or tier domain
at their end terminus a nucleotide
binding site that could bind and
hydrolyze ATP and c-terminal
leucine-rich repeat and it's
hypothesized at a resting state the
receptor is tightly bound and it's bound
to adp and so if a receptor directly
recognizes an effector and there are
cases of this what happens is you get
exchange of ATP for ATP this is a switch
for the active bound form of the
receptor so now it's on an on stage and
considered downstream can also get ATP
hydrolysis to potentially recycle it
back to an inactive state in indirect
recognition the model is similar except
the effector is not directly recognized
rather the NLR guards
a host protein that's targeted by the
effector or a mimic of a host protein
that's targeted by the effector and when
the effector targets and modifies this
guarded protein this acts as a switch
for receptor activation and other
outputs of effector triggered immune
responses in plants are kind of shown
here
and outputs of ETI or really if you're
looking at resistance or susceptibility
it's more of a quantitative phenotype
than a qualitative phenotype so you can
see here these are tobacco plants that
have the engine that recognizes the
portion of the tobacco mosaic virus and
you can see these resistant tobacco
plants there's basically no viral
proliferation but compared just
acceptable plants where you're looking
at GFP this is the presence of the virus
there
similarly in bacterial infection this
Arab adopts this line has the RPM one
resistant NLR you basically see no
symptoms after inoculation whereas
susceptible genotypes look very diseased
and at the at the cellular level a
common hallmark of effector triggered
immune responses is program cell death
at the site of infection so this plant
if you look under the microscope will
have patches of program cell death and
what we can do in the laboratory is go
in with a higher dose of pathogen and
then you can see macroscopic cell death
symptoms as well so work in my lab has
focused on one a key plant protein
called rn4 rn4 is conserved across land
plants and it's been shown to be
important for mediating immune responses
in lettuce tomato soybean and also a
rabbit OPS's and so what we know about
Rin for and a rabbit OPS's from work in
my lab and Bryan staska wits lab also
Jeff tangles up in Dave Matthews lab is
that it can associate with several
immune receptors and it's also targeted
by a number of different bacterial
effectors so at a resting state rn4 can
associate with the NLR RPM one and RPS
two holds it in an inactive state to
suppress effector triggered immune
responses but upon delivery of the
bacterial effector a vrb Rin 4 gets
phosphorylated and Rin 4 phosphorylation
was hypothesized to be a trigger to
activate the RPM one receptor leading to
effect or triggered immunity so this is
an example of indirect recognition now
we tried and several other laboratories
tried quite hard to see if a vrb was a
kinase that would be the most simple
explanation but we were never able to
detect kinase activity for a PRP so we
thought there had to be another host
kinase that might be playing a role and
what we did is we used mass spectrometry
and immuno precipitation to pull down
the Rin 4 and rpm 1 complex
upon activation and upon delivery of AVR
B and what we found is a kinase called
rip K and rip K is a receptor like
cytoplasmic kinase and we could show in
vitro that rip cake can phosphorylate
rent for at three sites and we mapped
those sites by mass spectrometry 3 921
Syrian 160 and three new 166 and three
nine twenty one and three and 166 were
conserved across Rin for homologues and
land plant and we had some evidence to
indicate that 3 D 166 would be a
critical region based on where it was
within the rim for protein so we
generated a phospho specific antibody
that would recognize phosphorylation of
3 D 166 and we can show that during
natural infection with Pseudomonas
expressing a BRB you get rin for
phosphorylation at 3 and 166 total
levels of run for at this time point
don't change and the bacterial effector
is also expressed and delivered then we
used a genetic approach to determine the
importance of Rin 4 phosphorylation for
activation of RPM 1 so we changed these
phosphorylated residues and mimicked
phosphorylation by changing them to
aspartic acid and then if we looked at
the resulting lines when we try to
complement rin 4 if we mimicked rin for
phosphorylation you see the plants are
so small dwarf their lesion mimics so
this is a hallmark for constitutive
activation of immune responses whereas
if we cross these lines into a genotype
that didn't no longer possess the RPM
want immune receptor
these clans looked phenotypically normal
and then using transient expression in
Nicosia Anna we also determined what the
critical residue was that's required for
recognition by our p.m. one and so here
if we co express our PM one with various
versions of rin for we can see that Co
expressing with a phospho mimic of three
nine one sixty six induces this
macroscopic hypersensitive response
which is a hallmark of effector
triggered responses and then if you look
at Rin for it doesn't look like it's an
enzyme of any kind although it's
conserved and it has a high predicted
level of intrinsic disorder so we tested
the hypothesis that potentially
phosphorylation might change a secondary
structure or some aspect of flexibility
we didn't see any change in gross
secondary structure and what we did is
we what we phosphorylated Rin four and
the presence of rip K using recombinant
proteins then got rid of rip k using
centrifugation and then subjected either
phosphorylated he run phosphorylated Rin
four to C D spectroscopy and you can see
here for wild-type Rin for you get a
peak at low wavelength and that's
consistent with this being intrinsically
disordered or random coil protein and it
you see stronger negative ellipta C in
the presence of phosphorylated Rin for
indicating that it's a more flexible
protein see similar things if we're
looking at wow hyper in four or a
phospho my medic mutant here by C D
spectroscopy and then we also searched
for potentially other players that could
play a role in early recognition of our
PM one and this is a collaboration
between my group in Chi Minh South at
Chinese Academy of Sciences and what
they identified was a point mutation in
a cyclo fillin that had enhanced at
activity but compromised our pm1
mediated recognition so cyclo feelings
are cisterns isomerases and they
catalyze this for a pepsi little pro leo
bonds and this is a rate limiting step
during protein folding and if we looked
at this particular point mutation within
rock one and we perform disease assays
using virulent bacteria here in the y
axis you can see bacterial growth on a
log scale and then this is days post
inoculation you can see there's not a
difference between wild-type colombia
and the rock one point mutation or any
null mutations within an alarm you know
scepters but if we look we could see a
specific effect after activation of our
PM one in resistant plants and so what
you can see here is that colombia can
recognize a VRB through the presence of
our PM one so has much lower bacterial
growth than here and then the rock one
point mutation was compromised in RPM
one recognition this here is the RPM one
on no mutant and then we did some
mapping of the importance of prolene
residues across ran for for activating
RPM one and mutated every single prolene
residue and first the graduate student
that was doing and i said don't don't do
that because that's gonna grossly mess
up the structure and you're gonna get a
lot of results that aren't gonna be easy
to interpret but i was wrong because
there was only one mutant that gave a
phenotype and that was purling at
position 149 so sometimes it's good the
students don't listen to you
and just go and do the experiment so
here what we've done is we've taken a
peptide of room for surrounding pearline
149 labeled it and then subjected that
to NMR spectroscopy and you can see that
this is the general structure and then
if we add in unlabeled rock one you're
still only looking at rin for what we
can see is specific isomerization
here and here surrounding prolene 149
that indicates that in vitro rock one
can isomerize are in for at position 149
and then when he tested to see what's
the effect of this on the ability to
induce rn4 phosphorylation so first if
we look in plants at this Rocklin point
mutation that has higher isomerization
capability that after delivery of a BRB
we see much lower ability to induce room
for phosphorylation and if we delete
prolene 149 from Rin 4 you can see that
at a basal level you much you have much
higher basal phosphorylation of Rin for
so this is our current model of RPM 1
activation we know that RPM ones at the
membrane it can associate at a resting
state with rip k rin for and rock one
and Rin for is isomerized by rock one we
predict at a resting state upon delivery
of a BRB AV ER b can dimerize with rip
k-rock one disassociates Rin 4 is now in
a sis conformation and it's prolene 149
residue this enables stronger
phosphorylation via rip cake and then
subsequently we know that rip K and ABR
be disassociate from the complex but Rin
4 and RP of one stay at the membrane and
you get activation of RPM 1 an induction
of defense responses so this association
with rock 1 enforces the inactive state
prior to recognition because you want
really close control over activation of
plant immune responses because there's a
energetic cost to inducing immunity and
enforces actually the active state after
recognition so you get robust immune
responses there and we've also done some
work to try to figure out why effectors
would actually target ring for in the
absence
of RPM one so I mentioned that there's a
large number of NLR immune receptors
that are present in plant genomes but
the NLR compliment can vary
significantly depending on the plant
genotype so our hypothesis was that in
the absence of our PM one Rin for
phosphorylation would enhance bacterial
virulence and this would be maybe one
reason why multiple effectors would
target Rin for because it's not going to
be beneficial to them if it's inducing
immunity and so you're able to show that
Rin 4 mediated phosphorylation inside
mesophyll cells suppresses pattern
triggered immune responses you get lower
extracellular Roz first altered mount
kinase kinetics and increased growth of
non adapted pathogens we are also able
to show a number of years ago on this
PLoS Biology paper that Rin 4 can
associate with a plasma membrane pump
called a H a and what we found was is
that phosphorylated ring for could mark
strongly associate with a H a and
induces enhanced activity and if you
look at plants that are phospho mimics
for Rin 4 but we see is that they have
wider Basil's to model apertures and we
also know that AVR B when you inoculate
Pseudomonas syringae expressing AVR B it
can also manipulate stomata apertures
upon surface inoculation so now I want
to switch gears and talk about another
kinase that we've been working on and
this is PDL 13 and pbl 13 and rip clay
are closely related
they're both members of these receptor
like cytoplasmic kinase --is so here is
just a diagram of the receptor like
kinase is and you can see these receptor
like cytoplasmic kinase is there kinase
domain is similar to the RL KS but they
lack an extracellular domain and there's
a number of different sub families
within the RLC case and one particular
subfamily called subfamily seven has
been demonstrated to be important to an
immunity in a rabid OPS's
and so here is just the phylogeny of
subfamily seven and why we became
interested initially in PBL 13 is
because it's closely related to rip Kay
and other members that are have been
intensely studied in this area are also
PBS five and BIC one and they all belong
to the subfamily 7 but pineal 13
actually looks different than these
other RL CK's and that's because it has
a unique amino acid repeat of 15 amino
acids that are repeated five times that
it's C terminus the rest of the RL ck
looks very similar to other RL CK's it
has all of the catalytic subdomains that
would you predict it would be an active
kinase it has a poem it elation motif at
its end terminus and we've shown that it
can go to the membrane as well so
graduate student in the lab Dan loon was
focused on the role of PBL 13 and so he
obtained two different t DNA insertion
lines in PBL 13 one's called PBL 13 one
and the other one which has a t DNA
insertion right before this amino acid
repeat and it's a truncated allele and
the other is PBL 13-2 that has a T DNA
insertion closer to the beginning of the
gene and is a true knockout and what we
found is that both T DNA insertions had
identical disease phenotypes which
indicates that this C terminus is
important for ppl 13 function and so
here is just phenotype after dip
inoculation with virulent Pseudomonas
you can see Colombia's disease you see
look yellowing here whereas the T DNA
insertion looks much better and if we
look either by dip or after pressure
infiltration syringe infiltration we can
see that these t DNA insertion lines
exhibit enhanced disease resistance
so here's bacterial growth on the y axis
and you can see both of these have at
least a log
decrease in bacterial growth so it's
pretty strong
type and we can complement this enhanced
resistance phenotype by adding an wild
type PBL 13 so it looks like PBL 13 is
an active kinase and indeed when we
performed in vitro kinase activity
assays with radio labeled P 32 you can
see that it is an active kinase we
already knew rip k is a kinase so we use
this as a positive control PBL 13 can
auto phosphorylate and transpose for
late a common kinase substrate and then
if we have this lysine mutant it's no
longer an active kinase and what we also
noticed is this is rakonin protein from
e.coli here wild-type EBL 13 migrated
abnormally large based on SDS page gel
whereas the kinase dead variant rounded
it's predicted molecular weight and we
know that by treatment was sipped that
this is due to heavy auto
phosphorylation and then we tested the
importance of kinase activity for its
resistance phenotype and we can see that
the PBL 13s kinase activity is actually
functionally required because you can't
complement the enhanced disease
resistance phenotype by adding in a
kinase dead variant of PBL 13 so we were
interested in what residues with in PBL
13 are actually phosphorylated so we
subjected a protein to mass spectrometry
and mapped phosphorylated sites and what
we could see is there a few residues
within the kinase domain that are
phosphorylated and there the serine
serine and threonine but if you look at
the percentage of the phosphor peptide
distribution we can see that the vast
these this correlates to one spectra and
around three spectra respectively but
the vast majority of phosphorylated
residues are present within this repeat
region and since it's a repeat region it
was a little bit difficult to actually
nail down unambiguously what particular
residues were phosphorylated so we used
a few different enzymes and we could get
some unambiguous spectra indicating that
likely this repeat of threonine serine
is phosphorylated on most of the repeats
so we're interested now and why actually
PBL 13 is more resistant we hypothesize
it's a negative regulator if we look at
the plants they don't actually look
phenotypically different than wild-type
or rabbit OPS's we don't have much
higher levels of Salus Toolik acid but
we do think that it did so there we
think it's actually but we do think it's
a negative regulator because it has such
a strong enhanced disease resistance
phenotype and we know that immune
responses have to be tightly regulated
there is a trade-off between plant
growth and plant defense and so the
timing and also the amplitude of immune
responses are tightly controlled within
the plant so these are just some common
outputs of plant immunity and we looked
at a few of them for PBL 13 so one is
you get this reactive oxygen Ross burst
this extra cellular Ross burst upon
pathogen perception this is by an NADPH
oxidase this extra cellular Ross then
serves as an antimicrobial it can also
lead to cell wall reinforcement and then
downstream of immune perception very
early events also or this calcium influx
which is an important secondary
messenger you also get activation of
specific map kinase cascades that lead
to transcriptional reprogramming in the
nucleus so we looked at a few of these
Ross and map kinase activation and what
we were able to show is that the PBL 13
knockout has enhanced map induced Ross
first so here what we do to measure the
Ross burst is we use a luminol based
assay and so here you can see the some
of the relative light units on the
y-axis and then the different genotypes
on the x-axis so when we add in a
bacterial map called elf 18 what we see
is that you can get rapid Ross
production in Columbia the PBL 13
knockout it has higher Ross bursts and
this can be complemented by one of the
PBL 13 complementation lines
also if we apply bacteria on immuno
genic epitope of bacterial flagellum we
can see that Columbia can respond to
this the PBL 13 knockout has an enhanced
response and this can be complemented in
the complementation lines the next thing
we looked at was map kinase activation
and here what we can see is that this
occurs between typically ten and fifteen
minutes after applying a recognized
microbial pattern here we're looking at
bacterial fly 22 application so you can
see a strong expression of
phosphorylated map kinases around 15
minutes after treatment but we see
faster expression at five minutes in the
PBL 13 knockout and then this is just
the flagellin receptor mutant as a
negative control and so both of these
are very early processes this is going
to hurt ker around 10 minutes after
bacterial or pathogen perception the
Ross burst occurs you know five just at
least by five minutes after perception
so we think that this is going to be an
early response so we're interested in
this Ross phenotype and previous work
out of Jimmy John's lab as well as
Searles lipples lab had shown that a
related kinase called Vic one is
involved in phosphorylating the NADPH
oxidase RB oht and RB o HD is
responsible for producing this
extracellular Ross it produces a super
oxide which is then rapidly dispute ated
into hydrogen peroxide and can serve as
an antimicrobial and what they were able
to show with Vic one is after flagellin
perception vic one is able to associate
with RB o HD phosphorylated and this act
to prime subsequent phosphorylation by
calcium dependent protein kinases
leading to enhanced activity so because
PBL 13 had an opposite phenotype as Vic
one we are interested in its association
with our view HD so here we're using a
split
zip erase a say where you can take one
protein infuse it to one half of
luciferase another protein fuse it to
another half of luciferase and then if
they associate you can see luminescence
within the plant and this is transient
expression in Nicosia Anna so here we
can see that PBL 13 can associate with
RB o HD at a resting state but opposite
to Vic 1 and rapidly disassociates upon
flagellin perception and this is a
negative control an aquaporin that's
also membrane localized to show that
there's no signal there we also looked
for associations by solute luciferase or
Co IP between primary immune receptors
and ppl 13 and we didn't detect that so
this is our current model for ppl 13
function and I should also mention that
we know that ppl 13 can phosphorylate RB
o HD c terminus as well and we're
currently mapping those sites by mass
spectrometry so we see that PBL 13 has
enhanced disease resistance it has a
higher Ross burst and faster map kinase
kinetics and we hypothesized that it
acts to suppress defense responses in
the absence of pathogen perception it's
unique among RL CK's because it has an
extended c-terminal domain that heavily
phosphorylated at least in vitro we're
interested in determining the importance
in vivo of pbl 13 c terminal
phosphorylation and we think that it
could compete with Vic 1 to regulate the
extracellular rossler's so we know
there's different pools at PDL 13 within
the plant cell potentially one pool
could be involved in suppressing
kinase activation because we know Ross
first and map kinase perception can be
genetically uncoupled but there's a pool
of pbl 13 cat that can also associate
with RB HD potentially phosphorylating
it at novel sites in order to suppress
activity in the absence of pathogen
perception but in the presence of
pathogen perception or elisa ters PDL 13
disassociates enabling Vic 1 to come in
and phosphorylate which then Prime's for
subsequent phosphorylation by calcium
dependent protein kinases
and an enhanced Ross burst upon pathogen
perception okay so now I'm gonna switch
gears and talk about the final project
and this is looking at the interaction
between a gram positive bacteria
pathogen cloud doctor Michigan Ensis
subspecies Michigan Ensis and tomato
so this pathogen causes bacterial canker
of tomato I've just shown some disease
symptoms here it proliferates in the
xylem vessels and if you look at an
infected tomato stem you can see
browning of the xylem here
there's also leaf symptoms where you can
this is called leaf firing stage or you
can get marginal leaflet necrosis which
is a hallmark of the disease as well and
then if there's a lot of bacteria around
flowering during flowering you can get
fruit symptoms these are called bird's
eye spots because there's a black spot
surrounded by a white margin or halo and
you can also get infection of the
vasculature of the fruit by the pathogen
as well sources of inoculum are infected
seeds infected tool stakes or
transplants the bacteria can also
survive several years on crop debris in
the field and when you have this canker
formation what happens is the bacteria
then we'll lose out get bacterial
streaming and in the presence of water
they can then move from one plant to
another plant so that can serve as a
secondary source of inoculum as well so
CMM has a high GC content its xylem
limited it's subjected to international
quarantine because it's particularly
problematic within glasshouse greenhouse
production and there is no genetic
resistance in commercial cultivars there
have been a few sources of resistance
that have been identified in wild tomato
species but they're primarily associated
with altered vascular morphology and so
they have negative horticultural
attributes that are associated with them
so they haven't been successful and then
trans
bring those into cultivated germ plasm
so right now the control standard
strategy is C disinfestation copper
sprays don't really works very well and
in the literature there's one completely
finished referenced genome that was
published a number of years ago so what
we are interested in doing is collecting
a large number of CMM strains to
represent the worldwide diversity and
then using phylogeny to sequence a
number of these streams and so here is
just a map that's highlighting the
geographical distribution of these
different CMM strains so we collected
from six continents over about six
decades and then used phylogeny of five
core housekeeping genes to try to figure
out which turns we really wanted to
sequence so we sequenced a number of
different CMM strains 34 pathogenic
strains and then five sacrifice so there
are closely related Club of actor
strains that are non-pathogenic that are
saprophytic so they kind of hang out
they'll grow a little bit within the
tomato but they won't cause disease this
is problematic because then if a grower
wants to test to see if they have
bacterial canker they're these will
light up with any kind of currently
based iliza techniques so this is
problematic for for disease control and
also if they detect that there's
actually Club of actor there they have
to get rid of all of their plans when it
could be just a pathetic Club of actor
now I mentioned that CMM has a high GC
content it's at least 72 percent so we
did Illumina sequencing but that became
and and it also has a number of
repetitive elements within the genome
but we couldn't get great assemblies
just based on Illumina sequencing so for
a subset of these we went in and did
PacBio sequencing as well and there that
worked quite well we were able to get
completely finished reference genomes
and completely complete plasmid
sequences just in a single shot
so what I'll talk about from now is
mainly our work on the pack
sequences and we also sequenced in this
number of 34 some CMM streams that were
collected within California as well so
in 2011 and also 2015 what we had in
California was this vine decline disease
which basically what we've found right
now is that it's a combination of fungal
infection of the roots as well as CLAB
of actor infection which combines to
have a decrease in productivity during
later stages of the disease and so most
of the tomatoes that are grown in
California are for processing and UC
Davis is in Yolo County that's where
they grow a lot of tomatoes so we've
collected a number of isolates just
right around the University in
collaboration with farm advisors and
also the San Joaquin Valley grows quite
a bit of tomatoes as well so what we
first looked at were the plasma
complements and as I mentioned there's a
prophetic cloud actor so this is one of
the saprophyte sweet sequence you can
inoculate but you don't see disease
symptoms plants look healthy this is
that one of the pathogenic strains that
we sequenced and this is the reference
genome that's been studied the most so
the reference genome has two plasmas PCM
1 and PCM 2 both are required for
disease symptoms so you can delete these
from the genome or cure them from the
bacteria bacteria can still replicate
but they don't cause wilting symptoms
what we found was there's a variation in
plasma complement among the strains that
we've sequence which is really similar
to what has been found for some of the
strains that have come out of Cornell as
well and around the Cornell area and in
New York so they have vary in their
plasma complement all the strains that
we sequence have PCM one but there's
variation in the presence of PCM 2 and
or presence of other plasmids and sapper
flights have neither PCM 1 or PCM 2 but
they have a novel plasmid that we call
PCM staff
and if you look at this circles plot of
the reference train and one of the
California strands for PCM one it's
similar for others you can see that
these lines here indicate that there's
homology and those genes are present
there's there's high homology between
the other strains and the reference
train with respect to PCM one and if you
look at bacterial growth PCM two is not
necessary because this California strain
can grow quite well just as well as the
reference strain and then like I
mentioned the saprophyte will grow a
little bit but not to the same extent so
we looked at the the genome to predict
secreted effector proteins so this is a
gram positive bacteria so it can't
deliver effectors directly into host
cells but it can secrete effectors
throughout outside of its own cell and
so what we found when we were mining for
the secretin is that there's a set of
about 40 effectors that are conserved
across pathogens and saprophyte there is
also around ten that are only found in
all the pathogens that we looked at and
then there's a variable number of
effectors as well if we look at these
conserved effectors most of them look
like that at least that have been have
assigned potential function would be
degradation enzymes or secreted
proteases and we also looked at the
presence of genomic islands and so
bacteria can acquire DNA horizontally
either through conjugation for plasmids
viral infection or through the
environment and this can be detected
based on their deviation and GC content
so if we look at the genomic islands
present between saprophyte s-- pathogens
in california and pathogens in the
reference strain we can see that most
there's only one large genomic island
that's present both in the reference
strain as well as all the other strains
that we sequenced and the other genomic
islands are variable and the genomic
island that's conserved is called the
CHP Tom a pathogenicity cluster
so I've just highlighted it here and you
can see it's quite conserved across the
reference train this is one of the
California strands and this is the
saprophyte where it's lacking so there's
been some work that's been done on CHP
Tommy on in club of actor we know if you
delete the entire genomic island it
abolish is pathogenicity if you delete
just CHP sea which is shown here in
yellow this is a serine protease it's
secreted that decreases virulence and
what we are interested in or is what
about some degradation enzymes because
you do get this canker formation
there's maceration of the host tissue
you get the stem splitting open during
later stages of a disease and we know
that the genome encodes several putative
degradation enzymes and so we unfocused
on the importance of two potential
dagger date of enzymes Pele one and Pele
two that are conserved that are pecked
8ly aces so if we look at Pele one and
Pele to their predicted to be secreted
they have a central and this is cleave
then afterwards we have a central pecked
eight lies domain if we look at
crystallized pecked eight licenses we
can generate high confidence models it
really looks like a peck date lies the
catalytic sites are conserved between
Pele one Pele to and characterize pecked
eight lysis and then if we perform
knockouts of either Pele one or Pele two
what we can see is that the Palais 1
deletion in cloud bacter has reduced
symptom morphology we don't see this
bubbly firing stage whereas the Pele two
deletion doesn't really affect bacterial
through Orleans and we can see a
decrease in bacterial growth but it's
not very robust here so this may be
affecting symptom morphology and not
necessarily bacterial colonization but
we need to go back in and look over time
and potentially look at movement within
the plant as well and then if we look at
expression of Pele one and Pele two if
we look in rich media both are expressed
at a fairly low level but if we look and
grow
the bacteria and xylem mimicking media
minimal media you can see that Pele one
is much stronger expressed than Pele -
and probably one the deletion is the one
that gives us a phenotype after we
inoculate on tomato so we've also used
these genome sequences to try to develop
diagnostic primers for growers and
industry to use so what we did is we
looked at our genome sequences of
pathogenic claw of actor saprophytic lab
of actor
we also sequence some genomes of a
related pathogen subspecies Cepheid
annika that causes potato ring rot and
we designed about 10 different PCR based
primers that should specifically detect
a pathogenic lab of actor but not zapper
fights and then we found two that very
robustly amplify and looked quite
specific one is based on a sugar ABC
transporter the other is based on a
transcriptional regulator and so we
provided these to growers to now use for
diagnostics where they wouldn't detect
these sacrifice or other pathogens so
just to summarize we've completely
finished genomes for about seven CMM
strings using pack vial use that to
develop specific PCR primers we know
these strains are not clonal there's
variation in plasmid composition genomic
islands also in secreto m-- we can see
there's about ten core secreted proteins
from clab of actor and we've started to
investigate a subset of these secreted
proteins for their role in bacterial
virulence um be conserved pele whiny
pecked eight lines is important for
bacterial symptom morphology but
deletion of a clustered and closely
related pecked a lie spell a2 has no
effect and not maybe because it's not
robustly expressed during infection so
I'd like to thank the people in the lab
that have done the work work on rin for
was initially started by June the
previous postdoc in the lab who's now a
faculty member at Chinese Academy of
Sciences
and also dung Hokulea a graduate student
has worked on that project as well work
on PBL 13 was led by a former graduate
student dan Lin as well as Dan Coakley
and then work on a club of actor has
been performed by a postdoc in the lab
cherie tapa and then Coast Thomas and
Jessica have also contributed to the rim
for project also I'd like to thank my
collaborators and then funding for
support thank you so the question was
because people 13 birthday are closely
related but it seems like they have
different functions the question is are
they redundant initially the reason why
you're interested if you DL 13 as we
thought that it could be functionally
redundant with ribcage might be able to
get more severe phenotype than a
higher-order beauties and we we tried
that so we have double mutants of PBL 13
in RIT okay but we don't see that there
is more of a significant phenotype let's
say with respect to activation of RPM
one or loss of RPM one activation than
just the 30 knockout
so I think they're actually doing
different things if you just look at the
central region it looks very very
similar to their case what we're trying
to do now is just take PDL 13 central
region and if we can see if we can
complement the route cannot have just
would act as compared with bullying but
I think there's something that's going
on with the seizure
that might determine specificity we're
also doing some kinase assays with
truncated PDL 13 versus full-length to
see if that changes ability to
phosphorylate particular residues of
event target protein yeah so bricky if
expressed in strongly in the route and
also within the leaves but more strongly
in the route and it has a much higher
expression than PBL 13 so ppl 13 is very
lowly expressed in the road as well as
in the leaf and it's a nothing to choose
but its expression level is quite low
sir he has
oh okay so the question was for citrus
greening is an edible after infection
well in in juicing industry for Florida
they can do certain things to the juice
like at sugars etcetera
and then that will still enable them to
sell the product you know during later
stages of the disease is going to kill
the citrus plant so then obviously yolk
will be reduced but part of the
phenotypes for citrus greening and why
they they called it citrus greening is
that you get this inversion of ripe the
ripening of the fruit so usually it will
ripen at the bottom first and then go up
and then here when you have citrus
greening you have green at the bottom
and then ripening at the top you get the
pathogen proliferate in the phloem and
so you get more bitter fruit because
there's Sloane blockage by kalos and so
there's decreased sugar accumulation
within the fruit so it's possible to do
some things for a juicing industry for a
fresh market it's not much you can do so
those questions of PBL thirteen's
general function is to dampen Ross as
the mutant have phenotypes in addition
to defense responses so that's a good
question we're looking at that right now
so some of these are BH mutants have
altered root morphology etc we know that
ppl thirteen is expressed in groups and
so I don't have the answer now but we're
looking into it to see if they can
phenocopy some of those
yeah and if they do then that would I
think that would indicate that there may
be additional functions for female 13
outside this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu